dump Trump Unleashed his midterm message
inside our nation's hotel dorm at USA
Today
predicting that if elected Democrats
will turn us into Venezuela where the
currency is printed on perforated rolls
because it's worth less than toilet
paper in fact toilet paper is a rare
commodity there never shake hands with a
Venezuelan socialist if William Devane
were doing commercials in Caracas he'd
be saying now has never been a better
time to buy Charmin because sadly toilet
paper is gold which they may not need
anyway because there's no food it's
gotten so bad zoos have become a sizzler
for the starving eating a zebra isn't
just for lions anymore
the Democrats see this is progress maybe
because the poor things are no longer
caged Donald Trump hit on this last
night you don't hand matches to an
arsonist and you don't give power to an
angry left-wing mob and that's what the
Democrats have become they would turn
our country so fast into Venezuela and
Venezuela is not doing too well folks
there's that M word again which should
never be used to describe threatening
hordes is it my behavior no it's not
Maura hey baby yes it's people who are
upset and they're angry with the way the
way the country is going and the
policies that these people please before
you jump in okay someone needs a timeout
meanwhile Trump says of the Democrats
lurch to the left quote every single
citizen will be harmed by such a radical
shift virtually everywhere it has been
tried socialism has brought suffering
misery and decay but maybe that's the
point what happens when you destroy
prosperity
well besides vacating zoos you vacate a
country and elect a Bernie it's the
Democrats version of the wall who wants
to come here if here is worse than their
the Dems backward-thinking actually
reverses traffic but maybe I'm wrong if
only there were examples of people
fleeing lousy places that once were
great before leftist took over oh yeah
Venezuela I think we have the Democrats
slogan for 2020 zebra it's what's for
dinner so I've noticed this
Jedidiah that the Trump's message is to
link the Democrats with Venezuela it's
kind of like with what he did with you
know crooked Hillary and what's that guy
what's slow I Nick or whatever that
sounds like a drink
yes he's doing that thing yeah well it
resonates he he he has a way of saying
things in a way that's very relatable to
people and that really hits home and one
thing that always strikes me is that
Democrats like to present themselves as
pro-choice on abortion of course they
make the argument we're pro-choice on
everything else they're anti choice and
when I was listening to what looking at
what he wrote I was thinking well the
Democrats don't want to give people the
opportunity to choose their doctors to
choose what kind of health care they
want they have some audacity calling
themselves pro-choice I know they limit
it to abortion but it's insane I think
the point needs to be driven home to
people why do you trust especially on
health care why do you trust bureaucrats
to do a better job for yourself than you
can do why because people government is
not God and the left likes to treat
government like it's a doer of good and
it's a public servant it's just a bunch
of bureaucrats that sit in rooms and
make regulations and make laws when it
comes to your health and your well-being
don't you want to be in charge decisions
for me one you know I think the
Democrats only hope in the midterms is
Donald Trump because you know you've got
about what 20-some odd days for him for
something to happen that will make us
forget the Cavanaugh momentum Cavanaugh
momentum well I think the big issue here
and it touches on socialism yeah
monologue is health care because I think
that is Jedidiah what people are upset
about I mean the number one issue for so
many people is high cost of prescription
drugs the viability of things like
Medicare and Social Security and so
right now this is amazing to me but
according to the polls you have 70
percent of Americans who support
medicare for all single-payer including
52% of Republicans and something like
Obamacare I'm sure any Fox viewer
remember
is Obamacare is terrible now Obamacare
has a majority support of the United
States of America maybe because they
feel like there's no there's no choices
left because it's been around when
something sticks around for a while and
I know this because I'm describing
myself people just get used to it never
get used to it people like you Greg yes
Jesse it's interesting that Donald Trump
actually penned a column in USA Today
but yet people at home under the age of
30 it's a newspaper it's kind of like
your phone except the stuff on your
phone is printed out that was me and
Greg what you said about us I can't
believe that I hope they never run any
of your columns
he should have written into the New York
Post or The Wall Street Journal maybe
perhaps but he does have a gift for
making big bold contrasts look how he's
setting this up America versus Venezuela
capitalism versus socialism greatness
versus misery and it's not just a good
midterm message it's a good general
election message because he's right the
Democrats once they got their claws into
healthcare they're not going to stop
there you just have to listen to what
they say they've talked about capping
CEO salaries they've talked about
guaranteeing housing as a right they've
talked about they've talked about
universal pre-k universal college in
California they're experimenting with
guaranteed income so their carbon tax
there's a lot of socialist ideas that
they're kicking around which are very
dangerous and if the Democrats get a
hold of any lever of government
especially the economy they are going to
slow down this boom so big wage growth
is going to slow down
investments going to slow down op
entrepreneurships going to slow down
it's going to be very dangerous this is
a very good message going into the
midterm Dana okay I know you have
something you want to say wait do you
think CNN got a memo about the mob it's
like you don't say the M word the M word
not just CNN it's across the board on
the left because what's happened is
President Trump has the ability to make
the contrast and he has the left on
defense so it's on his heels and you
have this the idea that now the
Democrats every on every show or on the
social media it's it's not a mob
we are not socialists we are not for
abolishing ice-like there's no proactive
message that they can get across because
he always has them just responding to
him right and so that's why he's already
setting up 2020 it's like basically it's
America versus you what do you wanna be
yeah America or the socialist it's a
great civics and economics lesson this
past three years it's incredible it is
one thing we didn't get a chance to talk
about this week because of all the news
is that for the first time in history
over fifty percent of the world's
population is middle class or higher
it's never happened before
it didn't happen without capitalism yeah
and we didn't have really a chance to
talk about that you know I think
capitalism is great the other day I was
at a ceremony and this young woman came
up and said you know so many people are
down on capitalism but the reality is
that if you involved not just profits
quarterly profits but you start talking
about stakeholders employees workers
investors it has made us richer but I
think that's why people are concerned
about the high cost of drugs in this
country and the high cost of I mean we
have we pay twice as much per capita as
any country in the world and yet we have
30 million people who are uninsured and
we know it's if you get a bad accident
it can be catastrophic for your economic
well-being in America totally
unaffordable though medicare for all
it's unaffordable I don't think so I
think their savings 32 trillion all
right lots of talk